he's one of our favorites here more the
all-time greats in the history of sports
and not only that in terms of giving his
thoughts giving his heart and giving to
the community writ large when it needs a
voice he is Kareem abdul-jabbar how are
you sir I'm good okay are you I'm doing
better for talking to you and I
appreciate your time I want to give you
the floor what is in your heart and mind
this morning Kareem abdul-jabbar well
you know it's kind of like I'm caught
between hope and history you know I hope
that our nation is going to make the
changes it needed to make to realize you
know its place and you know what it
means and how important it is that we
uphold what the founding fathers
actually talked about you know what mr.
Jefferson wrote in in a declaration and
all men are created equal we got to make
that a reality and I think the events of
the past week or so have really shown to
all of America how much that is not a
fact and that we had we have to fix that
we have to fix it what are your thoughts
your emotions when you're now in 2020
talking about what appears to be the
very same issue you were talking about
in the late 60s Kareem same issue I
remember the very first time I became
aware of it I was 17 years old and a
young man named James Powell was killed
by a police officer named Thomas
Gilligan ina and hahnemann manure riot
you know and I could have got shot I
could you know was just being out on the
street but it was dangerous and you know
it it hasn't changed any it's it's the
same exact issue the same exact issue
well Colin Kapernick I tried very hard
to demonstrate peacefully about this
very issue and what happened to him he
was ostracized he lost his job he was
black
and this is this is the issue he was
trying to talk about and it seems that
the powers-that-be did not like him
bringing it up so what would you counsel
today what will you what what what I I
guess in a way that's bringing it to
what you you wrote about in your op-ed
and I'd like to give you the floor on
that subject Kareem abdul-jabbar just
that people have to listen you know the
the criminal justice system is tainted
with racism from top to bottom it
discriminates and it makes people suffer
and that that has to end it has to end
we have to find a way how to make
criminal camps accountable you know the
good cops the overwhelming majority of
cops are good cops and they suffer too
when bad cops do what they do so you
know we need to find that some means to
hold bad cops accountable and keep them
from destroying everything that they
destroy families are trusted in the law
they say they they they squander the
good deeds of all the good cops so you
know something needs to be done about
that well also your headline make a
friend with someone who doesn't look
like you what do you mean that's a great
idea and understand their humanity and
understand that despite the difference
in looks they might like chess or
collecting stamps or whatever it is that
you like so you know find out what we
have in common
in our great nation it's a wonderful
place to do that so what does it mean
that that that would be here in 2020
fresh advice right I mean it's it's kind
of a simple thing to just suggest but
how do we I guess come together in that
regard Karine we we come together every
day I mean in our nation and especially
in the cities of our nation you know
people of incredibly varied backgrounds
come together and work together and
continue to make this the greatest
nation in the world that's it that's
what America is about
and we got to keep that happening we
can't let you know we can't let bias and
discrimination you know just make a mess
of it you know we can't do that what do
you have to find a way to cope what do
you think Muhammad Ali would think in
this moment Kareem well
Muhammad Ali spoke out numerous times
about police violence um it wasn't a new
issue for him you can go back and check
his his statements you'll see that he
actually spoke out on these issues
Kareem abdul-jabbar here on the Rich
Eisen show what would you suggest
politicians do people in power people
who could make change
what would usually empower I mean they
need to to talk to the people they need
to talk to each other and figure out a
way legislation legislatively to put
laws and in effect that will enable
people to eliminate bad cops that's it
just bad cops be amazed how much healing
that that that would promote if that was
a possibility that they could for the
things that they do is there any
specific part of the Constitution you'd
call people to to take a look at Kareem
I know you're you're somebody who knows
that document very well is there a
particular spot that you would say hey
person in charge X Y Z go check this out
well
the whole idea of promoting voting and
making the vote available making a
possible vote I think is a part of what
our democracy is about and to many
especially in red states that they're
trying to cut it back claiming that
there's voter fraud it's no voter fraud
voter fraud is not a problem in our
country unless the Russians are meddling
in our elections so you know we've got
to we have to make the the idea of one
man one vote and everybody equal under
the law we have to make those two things
a reality and I'm hoping that people can
hear that well I know you've written
about the Fifteenth Amendment in / in
particular what did what did what do you
want to bring to the people who are
listening right now are viewing right
now who may not be familiar with your
your thoughts on the subject
Kareem but just it you know just
consider all the efforts to keep black
people from voting you know in it is in
the reconstruction of the south any
black people were trying to vote were
dealt with it with violence that's a
tradition that's an American tradition
you know it black people voting in all
elections without harassment is a very
recent phenomenon and sometimes that
phenomenon seems to fade into the wind
okay so we got to make it possible for
participate in in our in our democracy
that's a month few more minutes left
here with Kareem abdul-jabbar Basketball
Hall of Famer are you feeling well
because before all this craziness hit
we're living in a pandemic right now
you're over the age of 70 telling any
tales out of school that you also had
some health history that could leave you
vulnerable what are what is your what
are you doing in this era of kovat 19
Kareem well you know I'm staying home
I'm involved in a new technology now
where I'm able to send messages to
people if you go to iconic calm you can
see what I'm doing if I send
congratulations for weddings birthdays
Father's Day any anything that you're
celebrating the funerals I couldn't
speak at that but it enables me to stay
close to my fans and you know if anybody
wants me to send a message to someone
they know and love I'm happy to do it
you can go to Icona gram calm and that's
just your you're staying inside staying
safe what would you say to what would
you say to athletes today about speaking
up speaking out and you know because you
you referenced Colin Kaepernick before
what would you say to athletes right now
about this very moment kareem become
speak the truth and like i said earlier
we have to reach out to all of our
fellow citizens and make make friends
with people who don't look like you we
can do that we're gonna we're gonna turn
this her own okay and before I let you
go Wes Unseld passed away today Kirill
what are your recollections about
competing with him and meeting him and
getting to know Wes Unseld Karine Wes
was a great guy you know he was like a
big roadblock on the on the basketball
court there's only like six seven six
eight but still couldn't get rebounds
over him because he just denied this is
on the on the court he was he was
awesome in that sense and he's a great
player and a nice guy and miss him and
my thoughts go go out to his family
Kareem I appreciate the time I know
obviously you're being asked to appear
in many many different shows maybe many
different programs to give your thoughts
on on the subject and you know I've
always appreciated you coming on and
next time
we could talk a little bit more sports
with you as opposed to life in general I
appreciate the time hope that sports
will be happening soon I'm missing it
just like you are I bet you are and
Lakers look like they were they were
heading towards another championship in
the case right there occurred like
they're on the verge there but you know
you got to play the games yes you do
and hopefully they'll be back playing
very soon we appreciate the time Kareem
thanks for the call
no problem you got it what you got
that's Kareem abdul-jabbar Basketball
Hall of Famer right here on the rich
Johnson show